kelly starts off this hour in sacramento
hi kelly how are you
hi dave i'm good thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
yeah um i feel like i'm in a little bit
of a tough financial situation
i long story short graduated with a
bachelor's degree and then later found
out i wanted to pursue nursing so i
am taking nursing prerequisites right
now paying for that
out of pocket um however i do have a
decent amount of debt and heading into
nursing school whenever i get there
it is going to be challenging to work
full-time while i'm in nursing school so
i'm trying to figure out if it's worth
it to take out
another additional loan basically just
to live
you know while going through nursing
school and trying to pursue this new
career
um how long have you been listening to
me
not very long to be totally honest with
you that's right that's okay that's
that's why i was asking because uh
because we teach folks not to borrow
money
okay period because
um what you said what was the phrase you
used you said uh
it would be uh you just say
uncomfortable you said something else
difficult that's what you said right
it'd be difficult to make it through
right now
without doing this right and the problem
is student loans
are difficult also
and so you're trading one kind of
difficult for another kind of difficult
and what we have found over 30 years of
helping people with their money and
particularly these student loan things
is
that you find some other way to do this
without debt
and then when you come out of nursing
school you're free
instead of okay i'm further in bondage
and i can't breathe
and i'm desperate to take a job so i
take a bad one
um and that kind of a thing so um
you've got nursing school paid for is
that what you're saying
no i i don't i am paying for uh the
prerequisites to get into nursing school
yeah
how are you going to pay for nursing
home school
um probably not the answer you want to
hear okay all right
but your plan before you called me your
plan before you called me was student
loans to pay for the school
and then your other question was do i
borrow even more to live on
correct okay i'm making sure i
understand the question okay cool all
right
well listen i gotta tell you i am a huge
fan of nursing as a career
having done financial coaching and
counseling
for 30 years my in general
nurses can always get a job and they can
always get extra jobs
that pay really good and so you're
always going to have work
i love your degree field that you chose
i think you're going to i think it's
going to cause you to prosper
particularly if you love people and the
healing arts and you want to be involved
and
helping people and loving people well
and that kind of a thing i think you're
going to be an
awesome nurse and i think it's going to
make you a lot of money and so i want
you to do this i just want to help you
figure out a way to do it
without going in debt head over heels
even more because i don't want you to
spend the next decade cleaning up a mess
because you had because you chose to do
this so what do you do now
uh i work for an athletic company for
their corporate team i'm working from
home at the moment due to clovid
yeah yeah okay all right yeah what i
would ask you to do
uh what do you do uh
uh honestly it's basically like customer
service
okay admin or customer service okay so
what what i'm gonna suggest you do is
you're a non-traditional student meaning
you're not a 22 year old nursing student
right
you're you're you're an adult you're a
grown up and all that
so i'm going to start looking for
scholarships that are aimed at
you and the other thing that's out there
is
if you'll start talking to some of the
hospital companies and some of the
medical companies in the sacramento area
or for that matter around the nation uh
are you married
i am not okay how old are you
25 okay so you could move yeah you could
move
correct so here's the thing step
companies like there's a huge
the largest hospital company in america
is here in nashville called hca
as an example okay and other companies
like them that own
lots and lots of hospitals are all over
you know america
in different cities and if you could
if you were to have conversations with
them you would find that they have a
nursing
shortage that you becoming a nurse
and being beholden to them is highly
attractive to them
i suspect you probably could find some
situations where you go to work for one
of them and they
pay for your nursing degree maybe you
have to promise to work there for three
years
or something after that but you get to
go to school free
okay that kind of a weird way of
thinking
is less difficult than
a hundred thousand dollars in student
loan debt plus twenty thousand to eat on
and now i gotta clean up that now i
gotta clean up that mess making 70 in
sacramento which is tough
mm-hmm and that's those are tough
numbers for you to push through
so i'm looking for scholarships i'm
looking for work programs with
medical companies that want nurses uh
doctor com you know companies that have
a bunch of doctors as a part of their
setup and they need nurses there's all
kinds of people
that will pay for you to go to school
you've just got to scratch around and
dig them up
and and that's harder now
but easier later
so i'm going to send you a copy of
anthony o'neil's book debt free degree
it's the number one best-selling book on
how to get a degree debt free
and there'll be some good hints in there
as well not all of it applies because
it's more of an undergrad thought
process for
a kid coming out of high school and that
kind of a thing but
there's it's a mindset thing to go
find the money without having to borrow
it
and a shift in your mindset and that's
what i want you to do
and i do want you to get the nursing
degree so hold on i'm going to give you
a copy of anthony's book
and we'll see if we can get you some
help and let me know how this turns out
i'd like to hear your story at the end